the Secretary General of NATO says that
support for Ukraine is making a
difference in the war with Russia Jen
sultanburg made the statement as defense
ministers from the alliance gathered for
a meeting in Brussels with Ukraine high
on the agenda
we don't see any signs from President
Putin from Russia that they are actually
preparing for peace on it or any real
negotiations but at the same time we
know that the more ground Ukraine is
able to gain through this
counter-offensive the stronger the hand
will be at the negotiating table and we
also know that the more successful the
Ukrainian counterfeit offensive is the
more likely it is that President Putin
at some stage will realize that he
cannot win this war on the battlefield
he has to sit down then when that will
happen how it will happen no one can say
that with certainty but the only thing
we know is that if we won't adjust an
enduring peace then we need to provide
the military support to Ukraine because
that's the only way for Ukraine to
liberate country land and to send a
clear message to to Moscow that they
will know Russia will not win on the
battlefield